this week on quadriga spy scandal
transatlantic trust on trial
documents leaked to the media say the
u.s has been treating the european union
as a target hacking its phones in
brussels
bugging its offices in washington and
spying on its offices at the u.n
the response from president obama every
country is up to the same kind of thing
i guarantee you that in european
capitals
there are people who are interested in
if not what i had for breakfast at least
what my talking points might be
should i end up meeting with their
leaders
that's how intelligence services operate
but our relations between the u.s and
the eu now under threat
your host this week melinda crane
hello and welcome so is the nsa scandal
turning into a major transatlantic
rupture or are we just seeing some
political play acting by european
leaders who don't want to admit their
own complicity that's what we want to
talk about today with three guests
who've been following the story closely
michel sturmer has been the senior
correspondent at the german daily
develop since 1989. he's a renowned
historian and has taught it a number of
academic institutions including the
sorbonne harvard and the university of
erlangen
daryl lindsey is the californian-born
and berlin-based editor of spiegel
international that's the english
language website of der spiegel magazine
he's worked for a range of american and
german publications including salon.com
and the frankfurter
algomanites and marcus beckedahl writes
about politics in a digital society for
netspolitik.org
it's an award-winning blog which is
widely read across the german-speaking
world he also serves as an expert to the
german parliament's commission of
inquiry on internet and the digital
society
daryl lindsay
let's start out with this uh latest
twist this strange story of the forced
landing of the plane of bolivian
president
morales nobody wants to take
responsibility for that do you think in
fact your country the u.s was behind it
i mean it's one can only speculate at
this point behind the evo gate as we
ought to be calling this but i think
nobody knows it we're researching it at
the moment but i think it's more of an
example of this sort of hysteria
surrounding this case in the west nobody
wants to touch snowden and i think this
is indicative of this like gossip and
hysteria can fuel things like this to
happen i mean this we're in a hyper news
cycle about this i think it's a small to
medium sized international scandal um
you know morales doesn't really have
any you know power that he can use to
retaliate for this so i don't really
think he has the cards on that but the
funny thing is that the u.s said not
10 days ago president obama speaking at
a press conference in africa said he
wouldn't be scrambling jets to try to
get a 30 year old hacker but it looks
like the americans are actually much
more disturbed by the whole case than
they want to let on well clearly behind
the scenes they're exerting a lot of
pressure on russia and other countries
and it's it's a huge national security
issue for them
on top of giving russia and china reason
to feel great schadenfreude now also
alienating the europeans the u.s has
already has once again angered latin
america which uh is a rather u.s
skepticish to begin with are we seeing a
major diplomatic disaster in the making
for the united states well give me four
weeks and we'll talk about very
different things
we had a major diplomatic blow up
years ago it was called echelon echelon
is still flourishing which is the
anglo-american
australian-canadian-new zealand
uh system of supervision and of course
spying that was state-of-the-art 10
years ago now it's state of the art
a little further advanced and of course
these are important things but they are
not all that important we agree on basic
things first of all we agree on
privacy as a principle and we break it
all the time our governments all our
governments do that whether they are now
shouting scandal or whether they are on
the receiving end of it
and we also agree on the fact that
there are bad guys out there in the in
the real world and the bad guys of
course not the
governments of
vienna austria or belgium brussels but
the bad guys come from
terrorist camp and it's a very
widespread camp chardon floyd on the
part of china and russia well i would
say mixed feelings because it could
happen to them and putin remembers said
he doesn't want
the the snowden can stay but
he shouldn't embarrass our american
partners he didn't say friends he didn't
say opponents he said partners
the us is doing a very good job of
embarrassing itself it's been looking
very clumsy and heavy-handed throughout
the whole scandal briefly why
why because it's toys for boys and these
things these technologies have their own
fascination and if you don't stop the
boys then they'll go on and on and on
this is a machinery run wild it's like a
car without brakes and you have to have
very close and very stern supervision
and that of course was failing these
things the homeland defense department
of homeland defense has now turned into
a monster nobody nobody including the
u.s president can control it
how we might get control of it once
again we're going to come back to that
in a second but marcus began let's talk
about that point that michelle schumer
just made namely everybody's doing it
that's been more or less the defense
that the u.s has used particularly since
the latest revelations came to light
last weekend regarding u.s wiretaps and
eavesdropping even within eu offices
both in the u.s and in europe
is everybody doing it is violation of
privacy the norm rather than the
exception
i'm not sure if everyone is doing it i
can imagine that a lot of secret
services are trying to spy on everything
they can do
but
what we see now with the british and u.s
american spy scandal is that they do
more spying on everything we couldn't
really imagine i come from the hakka
community we could imagine a lot
but within the last two or three weeks
we found out that there's much more
spying than we could ever imagine isn't
that simply crash course the real crash
course in indecency and scandal yes
isn't the fact that
is that the us just has far more
resources than anybody else these
programs are so comprehensive simply
because the us has a whole lot of money
they must be terribly expensive aren't
they yeah they have lots of billions and
they have no control as michel schterman
said and
we should always
mention that
the
most of the big
internet players are hosted in the
united states so companies like google
like apple all the nearly monopoly
companies they are based there and as
the prism scandal the first prison
slides showed they are doing
cooperations with the nsa
and so the nsa has access to our whole
digital life and the british
secret service is buying on our fiber
cables so our whole internet
communication is on the one side
being
stored on the british
data
engines and on the other side in on u.s
american companies
it's a silver platter
in what sense we are serving our we are
serving our data on a silver platter for
the nsa and the government
communications headquarters that the
british side
to use and any any secret service any
intelligence service of course is it's
being offered this great gift will use
it
you're telling us offered in the sense
of it's a formal process of data
exchange or you're suggesting that uh
perhaps german officials simply turn uh
their eyes the other way and and uh
it happens without we are not serving a
kind of
buffett supper
but
we are allowing ourselves to
sort of
channel
all our data in a direction where it can
be misused or used depending on your
point of view
and the private sector can do a lot more
than governments can i mean we've seen a
document that states that 80 companies
are working with the nsa directly in our
reporting at spiegel
and working on this so this is vast i
mean the problem with this is that this
is uncontrolled
absolute surveillance we we've known for
years we've always suspected that we're
being spied on that when you make a
telephone call somebody might be
listening but we now have documentary
evidence that this is actually happening
and it needs checks and balances i mean
america has very good reasons for having
pursued surveillance after after 9 11 in
the terrorist attacks we you know we had
we needed to catch osama bin laden um
you know we needed to find terror cells
around the world we needed to do a lot i
mean basically the cia had fallen behind
i mean we saw that in the in the war in
serbia in the bombings when we bombed
the chinese embassy i mean america had a
great need to improve our intelligence
and we've been doing that we went a
little bit too far i'm afraid and you
know we've used the argument that we are
you know trying to protect people from
terrorism but we've also seen documents
um within the nsa that show that they
are aiming for information supremacy
that's a very different argument
information supremacy is the way towards
absolute surveillance which means that
every minute of our lives they have the
potential to to watch that and i think
that's a huge civil liberties violation
the interesting thing is the nsa itself
has been around for a long long time it
was founded in the 1950s and your
magazine daryl lindsay which also broke
the latest uh story about the uh bugging
of the eu offices it has some very very
interesting excerpts from the spiegel
archives i want to come to that in just
a moment they re they relate to the
question of is everybody doing it to
what degree are european leaders
complicit this week we've heard some
very outraged protests here by european
leaders in indicating that they don't do
it and are shocked that the u.s is doing
it let's listen to a few of those voices
i feel treated as a european
representative of the european
institution
like the representative of enemy
is this the basis for a constructive
relationship on the basis of mutual
trust
if we're friends if we're allies
speaking honestly it's unacceptable for
someone in this relationship to behave
this way
it seems less like a relationship
between the us and its allies and more
like the old relations between the
soviet union and its satellite countries
this has to end as soon as possible in
fact immediately
we can only have negotiations or deals
of any kind once we've obtained these
guarantees
need to know that their intellectual
property is protected
and that includes not being spied on no
matter by whom
you need the issue of security plays a
big role in all of our negotiations
including in the trade talks we're going
to hold with the united states
michelle aren't these outraged protests
on the part of european leaders a bit
disingenuous the fact is as i just said
the nsa has been around since the 1950s
there's been a lot of reporting on its
data collection activities over the year
spiegel article from 1989 that could
have been written yesterday about the
degree of that intelligence collecting
here in germany now clearly not only
this government but also the opposition
which has also been in power in those
many years
from time to time must have known that
such programs were going on
well people tend to forget and people
tend to blow blow up small things like
martin schultz he's now in the business
of electioneering he wants to
he doesn't want to declare war on the us
but he sounds as if he wanted to talk
the first speaker he was the first
speaker and he wants to be the president
the first president of europe and of
course this is a gift to him
but he totally ignores first of all he
the the real world first of all he has
not a bit of government experience
except in a small municipality somewhere
in the provinces
um so he doesn't know how governments
are being run and once you are in
government you have a different view of
national security for instance then of
course there's plenty of open literature
you can buy it over the counter you can
also
download it in the internet uh on the on
the nsa on on 15 more
american networks this is not a
top secret world this is a semi-secret
world there's a lot of leaking
apparently also there were agreements
with the allied powers when they left
berlin in 1989 that they could continue
to gather information in germany gather
intelligence information so are the
germans essentially just letting
somebody else do their dirty work for
them what's going on here um
well there's a lot of i wouldn't call it
dirty work gray unwashed linen
um yes
we are also quite happy to receive
information from time to time remember
the so-called zawaland group a group of
would-be terrorists and we got the
relevant and for the key information
from the americans probably from the nsa
there was the other thing the other
terrorist attempt in bonn main station
where did where did we get the
information from
the lebanese
intelligence service of all people
so
our means are limited we need defenses
and the uproar now we have an uproar but
the uprobe would be huge much bigger if
there were in berlin a real terrorist
attack and someone had to stand up the
interior minister would have to stand in
front of television and say well the
americans would have offered us to us
but we said no we don't play with them
so much impossible marcus began clearly
other governments are profiting from the
u.s data collection activities
just don't want to admit it or
yeah
it's a giving and taking so
we allow the british we allow the
american secret services to spy on our
ground
because our bundesliga is not allowed to
do it
so
we asked the nsa to give us information
what's happening here and we are spying
somewhere else maybe in afghanistan
but
from my perspective the main question is
do we really want to have such a
surveillance on our society i would say
no
i want to spend my
online life
in a private in a privacy environment i
want to have a privacy online where i
work where i laugh where i communicate
with other people and i don't want to
live in a world where everything is
stored in a storage center in utah where
the nsa can use it when i next time go
to the united states they show me all my
online life
and say
and ask me do you want really want to go
in let me ask you this as somebody who
understands the technology well to what
degree is that vision that you're
outlining totally utopian in an era
where we are so transparent oh it's not
a utopian we are we are not really
transparent if you are
if you have a facebook account or an
online account somewhere else
you decide what's going public and not
maybe there are lots of information you
send in a direct message a direct
message is like a letter you send to
someone and you don't send it to the
secret service in the copy where or you
haven't done it in the past so but now
should it be normal i wouldn't agree and
if facebook is giving that information
without our permission that's an
absolute violation of our rights i mean
we have a right to hide things that are
online or to you know not share them
publicly i don't think there should be
an automatic assumption that when you go
onto a social network that that
information is public i for example am
very private i you know have the highest
settings i don't let people into my
profile
i i think you know we're the first
generation and specifically the two of
us that will have a permanent digital
footprint and i think we need to be
having a major international debate now
about what our rights are what the
limitations are um you know i personally
absolutely believe in the right to
delete data um i think that people
should be able to make requests to
google in companies like that you have a
digital eraser where you could go back
and change the record i mean it doesn't
look like it's going to happen the
european uh what is it the european
court of justice just issued a pre an
interim ruling last week that indicated
they're not going to make google do that
but this is the thing i mean we have
only had internet technology wide
available widespread for 20 years now
the the technology has moved faster than
the ability of society to set laws and
you know to have the ethical debates
about where we're going and now with
this scandal you can see how much
further ahead governments are i mean
that people haven't really had enough
time to think about this critically does
that mean that the technology has made
the risks inherent in nsa monitoring
greater than they were before i
mentioned the various historical
examples that they have been doing this
for over 50 60 years but you're telling
me that in an era of big data it's
entirely different it is big data and
that's the problem is it now that you
can take massive amounts of information
from different databases you can put
them together i could be denied medical
insurance if you look at the searches
that i've done on google oh i'm afraid
you know i kissed someone last week i
might have you know come down with x i
looked that up online if google's
storing every search that you have if
that's then being shared with government
what happens if america and i don't want
to sound paranoid i just think you have
to look at the worst case scenarios what
if america adopts a social healthcare
system of the kind that you have in
europe that's centralized it's national
and at some point they seek information
from google i mean that could create
problems
we have a very old and a very new
problem
the technology is far ahead of our
morality
and our political understanding let
alone our legal framework
technology is running out of control
it's really like a car without brakes
and we have to reign it in we who is we
governments
intelligence agencies international
community what about china what about
russia what about india will they play
along with us
i have my doubts
the world is a dangerous place and it's
getting
information wise ever more dangerous
what we haven't really
followed up is the statement by the
chancellor of economic espionage i think
that's a very important point
so far who cares really about 80 million
germans and their private lives
it's too much of material really
to be serious
no all right
but the economic side the industrial
espionage side that's really what we've
learned since the end of the cold war
the cold war was about military
confrontation and technology technology
race
now
we have we know that in china
they have divisions literally of cyber
warriors and they are out to get all
kinds of wonderful things and are you
suggesting the us is doing the same that
the commercial uses might be behind this
my argument is the world is full of
interesting things and the world is also
full of people who want to get access to
those interesting things irrespective of
their democratic credentials
and so you have to speak
within the terms of reference of the
real world not just the transatlantic
community of friends or of competitors
we are very ambiguous we are friends and
competitors
so marcus beckerdog us officials have
been making a crucial distinction they
say on the one hand we have data
collection metadata we're just storing a
bunch of phone numbers we're not
actually targeting people we're not
looking at every email that they write
we're only going into the substance of
this when we have court authority and
when we think there's a reason because
of terrorist issues that's the one side
and the other side is surveillance that
is done on targets if it's thought to be
justified by suspicions of terrorism do
you think that distinction holds up data
collection on the one hand surveillance
on the other oh i don't believe what
they told us it sounded like
that the nsa is just a little call
center
bringing telephone calls from a to b and
doesn't any
doesn't anything else
we have seen much thousand employees for
a call center yeah yeah
obama sounded like this at least those
jobs haven't been outsourced yet so even
if there's only this metadata as we know
you also mentioned what you can do with
the metadata it is a real data retention
what we we had this debate in germany
about sephora starting
you can do a lot of evil things if you
have such a lot of data basically but
i don't believe that the nsa is just
doing metadata
storage in utah they are now building up
a big storage center to
to store everything of our